was passiert eigentlich wenn putin uns
direkt ins visier von berlin nach moskau
sind sie ja bloß 1800 kilometer kein
problem für putins raketen aber was dann
eine supermoderne flugabwehr wie israel
die haben wir nicht schauen sie mal wie
das aussieht dort in israel dieser iron
dome dieser eiserne schutzschirm das
abwehrraketen netz der israelischen
armee brauchen wir das auch iron dome
für deutschland wir erklären ihnen mal
wieder dass genau in israel passiert
oder funktioniert dieser
raketenabwehrschirm
ein radar erfasst und identifiziert die
rakete oder die granate und überwacht
ihre flugbahnen die zieldaten der radar
erfassung werden an eine waffen
kontrolleinheit weitergeleitet und dort
ausgewertet aus den daten errechnet ein
computer den wahrscheinlichen einschlags
punkt wenn das angreifende geschoss eine
ernste bedrohung darstellt wird
sekundenschnell eine abfangrakete
gestartet die empfängt während des
aufstieges laufend aktualisierte daten
zur position des angreifers
iron dome zu deutsch eisenkuppel hat
eine reichweite von 570 kilometern an
der kuppel sollen bildlich gesprochen
alle feindlichen geschosse abprallen
jeder abschluss kostet bis zu 100.000 us
dollar bei allen dom gilt damit als
vergleichsweise günstige variante nach
armeeangaben hat sich die eisenkuppel
bislang gut bewährt die erfolgsquote
liege bei 90 prozent
der iron dome ist eine entwicklung der
israelischen rüstungsindustrie vorbild
sind die patriot abwehrraketen aus den
usa die unter anderem in den irakkrieg
1991 und 2003 zum einsatz kamen die
patriots sind im gegensatz zum alten dom
auf längere distanzen ausgelegt sie
können ziele in einer höhe von 30
kilometern und einer entfernung von mehr
als 100 kilometern treffen das
funktionsprinzip beider systeme klingt
simpel ist technisch aber sehr
anspruchsvoll wenn alles funktioniert
wird das angreifende geschoss in einer
genau platzierten spreng wolke zerfetzt
ja einen dom so funktioniert dieser
schutzschirm also in israel gegen
raketen brauchen wir so was auch gegen
putins raketen das sagt der chef der
konservativen partei im europaparlament
manfred weber heute bei bild live
oder nehmen sie das thema
raketenabwehrschirm wir haben in
kaliningrad raketen stehen die in
wenigen minuten berlin aber auch wien
erreichen können und deswegen müssen wir
doch überlegen ob den raketenschirm
nichteuropäische organisieren
darüber wollen wir sprechen jetzt mit
hartmut ziebs was machen wir eigentlich
wenn bei uns raketenalarm wäre wegen
putins raketen hat mozilla jähriger chef
feuerwehren des feuerwehrverbands große
herzlich
schönen guten tag zusammen was passiert
eigentlich das ist ein gedanke den im
moment millionen deutsche haben wenn
hier ein raketenalarm wäre wenn raketen
auf uns zugeflogen kämen beispielsweise
von putin
ja das wäre so ziemlich schlimmste folge
uns passieren konnte darauf sind wir im
moment überhaupt nicht vorbereitet das
heißt wir haben nach dem fall der mauer
alle vorsorgemaßnahmen alle wann
maßnahmen alle ausbildungsmaßnahmen
zurückgefahren wir wüssten heute kaum
wie wir die bevölkerung warnen könnten
bevölkerung ist schlecht drauf
vorbereitet und auch die zivilschutz
einhalten wissen womit gar nicht von wem
sie geführt werden dann das heißt noch
mal ganz einfach gefragt wenn eine
rakete käme beispielsweise aus moskau
oder umgebung dann würden wir es hier
erst erfahren wenn sie einschlägt
naja die behörden werden es früher
erfahren man wird versuchen die sirenen
zu aktivieren aber was dann die menschen
machen sollen ist den meisten unbekannt
wir haben auch gar keine schutzräume
mehr oder ganz wenige nur noch gar keine
berge mogelt und ein bisschen menschen
etwas immer so ein alarmsystem mit sms
sofort oder whatsapp aufs handy das gibt
es ja in israel seit so vielen jahren es
ist für uns wenn wir in israel sind
wahnsinnig beunruhigend und gleichzeitig
irgendwie beunruhigend über beruhigen
dass man dann ein denkt dass man gewarnt
wird ist das kompliziert so was
einzurichten auch in deutschland oder
könnte man das einfach kopieren
nein das kann man kopieren und da sind
auch die regelungen jetzt entsprechend
geschaffen das heißt dass wird der bund
einführen das ist ein schritt zur lösung
des problems aber das alleine reicht
nicht wir müssen also schutzräume bauen
wir müssen letztendlich den ganzen
zivilschutz neu organisieren wieder
reformieren natürlich auch mit
finanziellen mitteln ausstatten um nicht
die zivilbevölkerung ein teil der
zivilen verteidigung wieder
sicherstellen zu können im moment können
wir nicht wüssten sie aktuell für sich
wo sie dann hin müssten also wissen sie
wofür sie der nächste bunker wäre
ja das ist immer das problem wenn man
selber feuerwehrmann ist ja ich habe
mich mit der frage schon lange
beschäftigt und ich wüsste wohin ich
gehen muss ja dann verraten sie es
möglichst vielen ich danke danke ihnen
herzlich für das interessante gespräch